I want to leave you with with a thought
we've heard a lot about data and all
these new sets and a friend of mine that
a lot of you know probably play Shirky
i'm going to paraphrase him he said
recently that it's no good giving people
a dashboard if you don't give them a
steering wheel to go with it and I think
that's maybe a takeaway and maybe
something to explore the next time we
get together is the data is the start of
it but then you need to have that
steering wheel to go along with it so um
so please think of that mol Matt and I
want to give you I do not have a pop
quiz as Andy Grove suggested but I do
have an assignment what I'd like you to
do following what Nick Felton suggested
I want I would like you if you're so
inclined to take a couple minutes after
after we leave that for you walk out
here and two if you have a Twitter
account to tweet the number of
meaningful encounters you've had the
couple days so I'm just curious I think
it would be fascinating to see as an
experiment what what you all might
quantify in terms of the meaningful
encounters the conversations the
interactions the ideas you've had and
let's keep that going and so for the
live feed for those people thank you for
joining us and for all of you here
please head out and have a drink on us
bye bye